Speaker 1: There are 21 Republicans who voted
against awarding medals to the police officers in
Washington, D.C. Speaking of fighting off attacks,
the the police officers in Washington, D.C.,
who quite literally fought off attacks from
Trump rioters. On January 6th, the House
overwhelmingly passed legislation to award the
Congressional Gold Medal to the police officers
who defended the U.S. Capitol during the January
6th riots. Lawmakers approved the award by a vote
of 406 to twenty one. But wait a second, sir.
Twenty one no votes. Where did those come from?
The twenty one no votes were, of course, all
Republicans and all supporters of Donald Trump.
Some have tried, as Newsweek writes, to
downplay what happened on January 6th.
Others have been previously linked to Kuhnen
conspiracy theories. Congressman Thomas Massie
of Kentucky says that this could have an effect on
the hundreds of suspects who have been charged in
connection with the events of January 6th. Massey
saying, I think if we call that an insurrection,
it could have a bearing on their case that I don't
think would be good. If they just wanted to give
the police recognition, they could have done it
without trying to make it partizan, making the
case that if you just wanted to give medals but
not refer to what happened as an insurrection,
maybe Massey would have gone for it. But when
you call it an insurrection, you're politicizing.
Radical Republican Congresswoman Marjorie
Taylor Greene of Georgia said she voted
against it because it referred to the capital
as a, quote, temple. She also said I wouldn't
call it an insurrection. Congressman Scott
Perry of Pennsylvania said it's all politics,
it's all garbage. So here's the list of the twenty
one that voted against it. Many of these will not
surprise you. Andy Biggs. Lauren Bobert is, of
course, on the list. Michael Cloud, Andrew Klyde,
Warren Davidson, Matt Gates and Louie Gohmert.
No surprise to see them on the list. Bob. Good.
Paul Gosar is a disgusting radical, of course.
Marjorie Taylor Green, Andy Harris, Jody Hice is
on the list. He is absolutely vile and disgusting.
We've talked about him recently, Thomas Massie,
who I just quoted, Mary Miller, Barry Moore, Ralph
Norman, Scott Perry, John Rose, Matt Rosendale,
Chip Roy and Greg Steube of Florida. A number of
lawmakers expressed outrage at representatives
who voted against it. Adam Kinzinger tweeted, How
can you vote no to this is beyond me? Then again,
denying an insurrection is as well to the
brave capital and D.C. Metro PD. Thank you
to the twenty one who voted against this, they
will continue to defend your right to vote no
anyway. You know, for me, what is I hate when we
look at a political issue or an issue that could
be a political issue and then realize it's just
posturing for optics. I hate that because I find
it to be a form of grifting. It's. Claiming to
care about something when you really don't, it's
a version of playing a character publicly that
is not really who you are, they back the blue,
they support the police, the thin blue line, all
of this different stuff. And then all of a sudden,
hey, let's award these officers for what they did.
It's the same very police that you claim defending
against any reduction in funding is your
patriotic duty. Let's let's award them. Oh, no,
no, no, no, no. Why? Well, the word insurrection
was in the bill. The word temple was in the
bill. And this goes back to what is fundamentally
Republican support of institutions that they deem
worthy to their political world view without
really giving. What about the individuals?
And I go back again to this example of the
Iraq war when George W. Bush was president,
it was all about support the troops, support the
troops, support the troops. And when people on
the left like me said, hey, you know what? If
we send troops into harm's way because of a lie
about who actually attacked us on 9/11 and we send
them to Iraq, that's not supporting the troops.
That's blindly supporting a neo conservative
Republican president who wants to finish what he
sees as the job his father, George H.W. Bush, left
undone in the early 90s. That's not supporting the
troops. I was called unpatriotic. So it's not
about supporting the troops as individuals get
them health care when they come back and make sure
we treat PTSD seriously as opposed to some kind of
character flaw. It's about supporting the troops
means hope that they go and kill a bunch of
people and turn a blind eye to what a Republican
president wants. That's what they mean. And it's
very similar with what's going on with support.
The police here are some police you can support.
Well, no, we mean just funding departments
so they can get tanks and shoulder mounted
RPG. So these these are individuals. We don't
really care about them. That is at its core what
this is really about. Let me know your thoughts.
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman.
The David Pakman Show is made possible by
viewers like you who sign up for membership
at Join Pakman Dotcom, consider yourself
invited to grab a membership on my Web site